number of human rights defenders have
urged Israeli authorities to stop a
spring dangerous herbicides over
territory in Gaza in a letter to
military officials they insist that it
contravenes both Israeli and
international law according to the
document the latest case of so-called
farm warfare took place in early
December along the Gaza border the write
scripts mentioned that Palestinian
farmers have previously sustained
massive losses as a result of chemical
spraying the agent glyphosate switch has
been restricted or banned in many
countries over fears that it causes
cancer is allegedly the main herbicide
used by Israel there's a greenhouse
several kilometers from here the aerial
spray drifted that way and ruined all
the plants inside even though the
greenhouse was closed we don't know what
to do is the same thing over and over
again every year there spraying ruins
all the plants in the vicinity and
leaves nothing for us to harvest along
the border
it also poisons people makes them sick
the herbicides affect the plants they
don't kill to fruits and vegetables
still contain traces of them the
pesticides affect everything they touch
we grow about 30,000 plants around here
and losing our harvest is very costly
what can I do now though that I've lost
all my plants who can we talk to about
this problem so that I am compensated
for it it's been more than a year people
seem like they've completely stopped
caring farmers don't even bother calling
Agricultural officials anymore because
they know it's pointless the so-called
experts come from time to time to tell
us there's something wrong with the soil
here but it's not true
farmers have been around here for over a
decade and now suddenly the soil is to
blame these really defense forces have
given our tea a comment on the situation
they said they have had to spray
chemicals along the border fence to
prevent it being covered by vegetation
all the pesticides being used to
hazardous to humans they can cause
cancer and lead to respiratory problems
they're a threat to our health even if
they do only spray them on their
territory like they say they do
the chemicals reach our land with the
wind and caused enormous harm to people
and this is not the first reported case
at least eight claims were previously
filed in Israel with farmers seeking
compensation for damage crops they were
all rejected by the defense ministry
which stated that Israel was quote not
liable for damaging Gaza the Red Cross
has also repeatedly expressed its
concern over chemical spraying there
a human rights campaigner we spoke to
says that Palestinian and Israeli
farmers should be treated equally I
believe the Israelis have pesticides is
a violation of international human
rights law and even Israel's own laws
banning certain hazardous chemicals they
need to be banned because the wind
carries them and is not only Israelis
who are affected as a human rights
organization is our duty to monitor
potential violations
we contacted Israeli officials on
several occasions seeking to end the use
of herbicides along the Gaza border and
several lawsuits have been filed in
Israel by those affected by these
practices there have been cases where
the Israeli government has paid
compensation to Israeli farmers and
that's what we are asking for
Palestinian farmers on both sides of the
border they should be treated equally
and the spraying of herbicides needs to
stop this is not just a matter for
Israelis
you